today we're doing Thomas Edison there's
a lot to unpack but first I do want to
mention a word from our sponsor
brilliant bar sponsors they make this
show possible so if you want to support
us please do consider trying out
brilliant they're a fantastic way to do
that so brilliant are a science learning
platform that allow you to learn through
something called active learning you've
heard me talk about this at length
before if you've been watching by
graphics for any time it's an amazing
way to learn basically summed up is the
opposite of the feeling of when you you
know you read something in a I don't
know a magazine or a textbook about some
complex principle and you're like I just
don't get it I just don't understand
because you know you're not ever being
asked to apply that knowledge that
you've just learned with active learning
what you do is brilliant give you a
paragraph to read it's about a complex
topic but then immediately after that
short bit of information you have to
apply it to a problem which ensures that
you've understands it and it really
helps kind of cement that in your minds
which is an amazing way to learn all of
brilliance courses are totally
interactive so you can learn probability
maybe by playing a game of blackjack or
learn the physics of emotion using
interactive models of pendulum clocks if
you want to support biographic sand get
unlimited access to all of brilliance in
depth math and science courses and of
course their daily challenges which I
haven't even mentioned which are
fantastic they're just a short way to
learn you know just if you got five
minutes a day you can hit a daily
challenge and it's a great way to learn
if you want to get all of that stuff
just head over to brilliant at org
forward slash bio graphics you're at 20%
of their annual premium subscription
like I say this is just one of the
easiest ways that you can support what
I'm doing with my graphics I appreciate
it and let's get on with Edison
[Music]
hundreds of people stood in a crowd in
front of the Menlo Park Factory in New
Jersey as a banner unfurled
to reveal the image of Thomas Edison he
wanted the world to know that he was the
most important person in the room he was
the brand he was the inventor he was the
one in charge of over a thousand
machines that were created under his
name Thomas Edison has become a
polarizing figure in modern history some
believe that he was a genius inventor
and a brilliant businessman who changed
the world as we know it others believe
that he was manipulative and he stole
the ideas of other greater minds the
truth well it's somewhere in between
on today's by graphics we are going to
dive into the incredible life of Thomas
Edison today Thomas Edison is considered
to be one of the greatest American icons
of all time surprisingly though his
family history started out as the exact
opposite of the American dream his
grandfather
Samuel Ogden Edison was a loyalist
during the Revolutionary War so he
decided to move the family to Canada and
pledged his undying allegiance to King
George the third Thomas Edison's father
Samuel jr. was later exiled from Canada
for being a part of the Mackenzie
rebellion this was a revolt against the
oligarchy who was in control of the
local governments Sam Edison and his
wife Nancy had no choice but to move to
the United States they had a total of
seven children but three of them they
died during infancy Thomas Alva Edison
he was the youngest child in the family
and he was born in 1847 in Milan Ohio he
and his family moved to a farming
community in Port Heron in Michigan he
only had three months of formal
schooling before working on the family
farm his mother Nancy actually had
several years of education behind her
from the time she was in Canada so she
taught him how to read and write at home
Edison continued to read as many books
as he could get his hands on and he had
a natural curiosity for the world around
him he sat on goose eggs to see if he
could get them to hatch and set a
neighbour's house on fire just to watch
it burn because well you know boys will
be boys right when reflecting on this
time Edison said
just a bunch of devilish hijinks even as
a young boy Edison began to dabble in
chemical experiments in his parents
basement he eventually got some fresh
air by working as a newspaper boy for a
local railroad at 12 years old since si
was spending so much time working he
wanted to continue his experiments
whenever there was downtime so we began
tinkering with chemicals in one of the
train cars and accidentally started
another fire as you can tell setting
fires it seems to be a bit of a trend in
young Edison's life not surprisingly he
was asked to pack up his chemistry set
and never return since becoming a
newspaper boy didn't work out
Edison decided to learn a valuable skill
he taught himself
Morse code no one ever taught him how to
do this so Edison spent up to 18 hours a
day sending and receiving these messages
in Morse code in order to become
proficient at the skill by the time he
turned 15 he got a full-time job as a
telegraph operator for one of the local
newspapers he received the news from
far-off publications and was able to
write down the basic information before
handing it off to the writers it was
around this time when he began going
deaf it's possible that the loud trains
he worked on as a young boy and the
nearly constant tapping that he had to
listen to for most of his life
contributed to this very early hearing
loss here was always hyper focused on
the task at hand getting better and
better at translating Morse code you see
Edison was always hyper competitive and
he wanted to be the best operator the
was he once wrote that his hearing was
so bad all of the background noise of
the other operators faded away the sound
of their machines was drowned out in a
low muffle and the only thing he could
hear was the tapping of his own
Telegraph because of this he spent a lot
of time thinking instead of making
friends at work he scarcely spoke to his
co-workers and concentrated on the
machines instead eventually Edison asked
to work the night shift so it was always
doing overtime for a total of 16 hours a
day as a night there was scarcely any
news coming in over the wire so Edison
had plenty of free time to tinker with
the machines he wanted to know how they
worked and how they might be improved it
wouldn't be too long before he figured
out how to take his beloved Telegraph
machines to the next level
when he was 22 years old Thomas Edison
decided to leave his job as a telegraph
operator and moved to New York City at
this point he had studied the telegraph
machines so closely that he knew how to
manufacture them from scratch and he
made far more money creating and selling
the machines than he did as a mere
operator New York City was right in the
midst of the Industrial Revolution
movie stars didn't yet exist so the real
heroes of America were the inventors
everyone wished that they could come up
with a brilliant new idea and file a
patent which would lead to fame and
fortune their name it would be published
in the newspapers and the magazines and
they would become a permanent part of
history for years Americans had
struggled to find their sense of
national identity they didn't have the
great architecture of the universities
that you could find in Europe and many
people considered most things in the
young nation to be a bit subpar but once
Americans became the masters of
innovation many young men from all over
the world began to immigrate to New York
City in order to become the next great
inventor Edison began to receive more
and more orders for his new Telegraph
machines and he had a good business
going for himself he started to hire
other men to put the pieces together in
order to have more time to tinker on his
own as time went on he began to create
Telegraph's that could print out
messages he also developed the patent
for a multiplex Telegraph which could
send out several messages at the same
time making these new machines only
attracted more and more customers to
order from him instead of the
competition in 1871 he was 24 years old
when he met his wife Mary's still well
they got married he was 24 she was only
16 their two children together and she
immediately set out helping him with his
meals clothing and other essentials so
that he could continue to concentrate on
his work Edison worked throughout the
day and night to fulfill his orders he
scarcely stops to sleep or eat because
there was just so much to do he once
said the reason a lot of people do not
recognize opportunity is because it
usually goes around wearing overalls
looking like hard work after a few years
of this pre hardcore lifestyle Thomas
Edison began to make a lot of money from
his Telegraph business a 29 years old he
invested nearly all of his earnings from
those seven years into a laboratory in
Menlo Park New Jersey the audit team of
men who
or shared a vision that Menlo Park could
become the world's first think tank it
was a place where inventions they could
happen he wanted to be the world's very
first full-time professional inventor
his family moved into a house that was
built on the same property as the
factory even though he was working close
to his wife and children they almost
never saw him because he spent almost
all of his time working tonight he would
walk home and immediately go to sleep
the one and only day he took off was
Sunday for church and rest Edison once
wrote to a friend that he had a goal of
creating a minor invention every 10 days
and a major breakthrough once a month of
course this would be impossible for one
man to do alone he would give his
employees assignments to work on
specific projects or ask them to find a
solution to a problem since yet multiple
teams working on these new inventions
every single day they were able to come
up with new breakthroughs once they
finished a new invention he would patent
the idea and his own name and reap the
benefits of its profits in 1876 there
was a massive exhibition in Philadelphia
where investors showcased their new
ideas this is where Alexander Graham
Bell displayed the very first telephone
this invention threatened Thomas
Edison's livelihood it would make the
Telegraph completely obsolete after all
if you could hear someone's voice why
would you bother listening to Morse code
to communicate over the Telegraph Thomas
Edison he immediately decided to try and
improve on the telephones design he once
said an inventor needs an enemy Bell was
from a well-to-do family and had a
college education he also had plenty of
money handed to him from his
father-in-law to tinker with his new
inventions Edison was motivated to
compete with him and just a few months
later his laboratory developed an
improved version of Bell's telephone
that could be patented itself he had
once figured out how to write from a
telegraph based on the vibrations coming
from the Morse code he thought if it
worked on paper why not something else
he placed a needle on top of a sheet of
violins began to speak loudly into the
phonograph the first ever thing he
recorded was the child's nursery rhyme
mary had a little lamb after years of
improving on other people's inventions
his kaleidoscopic Minds had finally
rearranged all of the knowledge that he
had collected this was his first
completely original invention I was
taken aback he said I was always afraid
of anything that were
the first time in 1877 Scientific
American published the story about
Edison's phonograph reporters from all
over the world rushed to Menlo Park to
see the new device firsthand Edison he
knew how to be charismatic and he played
to the crowd when the reporters showed
up he would offer them slices of pie and
cigars while he told them entertaining
stories
this made the reporters to like him and
they would write about his brilliant
mind and his impressive laboratory like
any businessman who knows what he's
doing you can bet that he immediately
took full advantage of all of this Free
Press
he ran ads in newspapers offering to
sell a phonograph to anyone in America
thousands of people would have read the
news and they wanted to order these
machines for their own homes
now instead of producing Telegraph's the
Edison Factory was also selling
telephones and phonographs and he became
incredibly wealthy newspapers continued
to print stories about his personal life
because they believed he was exactly
what they would imagine as the perfect
all-american inventor on April Fool's
Day one newspaper printed a story that
Thomas Edison had come up with an
invention to turn dirt into food and
even wine even though this was
completely ridiculous people actually
fell for it because they thought that he
truly could invent anything he began
receiving fan letters and interview
requests on a daily basis people would
ask for money
favors and just about anything you could
think of Edison spent a significant
amount of every day answering these
letters and speaking to reporters which
took even more of his free time away
from his family after a while being a
public figure it became so overwhelming
that he was no longer getting any work
done in the factory at all in 1878
Thomas Edison decided to go on a trip to
Wyoming so that he and a group of men
could watch the solar eclipse his wife
Mary was pregnant with the third child
she felt sick and she became very
anxious especially with so many people
knocking on their door looking for her
husband doctors roads to Edison that he
needed to return home immediately
because she was too ill to be left alone
instead of rushing back to his pregnant
wife Edison ignored the letters he was
used to Mary complaining this he worked
too much and he usually ignored her
pleas for help so he finished out three
more weeks of his trip
sadly Mary was more than just anxious
she truly was sick for the next few
years
her health continued to decline
[Music]
soon after the birth of his third child
Thomas Edison did the opposite of
slowing down and enjoying his time as a
father he began his most ambitious
project yet the light bulb plenty of
other inventors had come up with light
bulbs before but they burned out after
just a few minutes so he decided to come
up with a solution in just a few days
Thomas hasn't figured out how to have a
long-lasting incandescent light bulb
since the journalists were waiting with
bated breath to find out what he would
do next this became an overnight
sensation investors were suddenly
showing up at his door and handing him
money an Edison stock it went through
the roof they wanted to support his idea
to create a society that no longer
needed to rely on dirty oil lamps in
order to bring light into people's homes
he announced that he would do the
impossible
he would light up New York City so that
it shines even at night by the summer of
1879 New York City was still not filled
with electric light bulbs as promised
and Edison Starkey began dropping as
people began accusing him of lying in
order to manipulate the market he began
to lose hope this an electric city could
ever exist behind the scenes workers in
Menlo Park were hustling day and night
to get the light bulbs working of course
the task was much more difficult than
Edison had ever anticipated they needed
sockets wiring and an electrical system
that must be installed into a building
before appliances could work they also
needed to create massive generators he
wanted to achieve this using DC or
direct current however the DC power
generators they broke down very easily
and he needed to hire someone to come up
with a solution to the problem his
saving grace was none other than Nikola
Tesla he was the true natural-born
genius with an eidetic memory which
meant that he could recall objects from
memory and recreate them perfectly after
spending years working on DC power in
Budapest 28 year-old Nikola Tesla
decided to leave Europe on a boat for
New York City after hearing so much hype
about the American dream
Tesla was actually disappointed once he
arrived he said what I had left in
Europe was beautiful artistic and
fascinating in every way what I saw here
was machined rough and unattractive it's
America is a century behind Europe in
civilization despite being a bit and
well my the scenery he was still caught
up in the enthusiasm for invention
almost immediately after arriving in the
United States he approached Thomas
Edison and asked for a job once Tesla
learned about the issues with the DC
generator Edison made him a deal he said
that if he could come up with a solution
to the problem he promised to give him a
$50,000 bonus with modern inflation
that's closer to one and a half million
dollars edison truly underestimated what
a hungry genius can accomplish with that
kind of money on the line in only a few
months Tesla had fixed all of the DC
generators when he came to collect his
$50,000 reward a doesn't brushed it off
saying that it was a joke he blamed it
on Tesla's inability to understands the
American sense of humor it wasn't
falling for it though Nikola Tesla
immediately quit his job and decided to
go into business on his own when he was
repairing Edison's generators he could
see all of the problems so he invented a
much better version called alternating
currents or AC power Edison's direct
current could only move in one direction
there needed to be generators every mile
in order for the system to work but
Tesla's alternating currents bounced
back and forth and it could vary in
voltage this meant it could go hundreds
of miles in between generators Tesla
patented the technology but it would be
an expensive undertaking he tried to
show it to investors but most thought it
was impossible and they weren't willing
to compete with Edison
that was until Tesla met George
Westinghouse together they spent the
next few years plotting to create a
system that would defeat Thomas Edison's
electric lights in the midst of this
current war
Edison's wife Mary died in 1888 she was
just 29 years old the doctors say that
she had congestion of the brain which
was a blanket term given to such an
intense level of depression and anxiety
that it led to high blood pressure and
stroke when she first met him Mary was
just a 16 year old girl he married a man
with a small Telegraph business there
was nothing that could have prepared her
for the pressure of being the wife of a
celebrity since Edison was devoted to
his company nearly 24/7 it only makes
sense that he met his second wife at
work two years after Mary's death Thomas
Edison married a woman named Mina Miller
her father was also a well known
inventor and she had grown up around
famous scientists this inspired her to
work in one of Edison's factories in
Newark
she had a keen scientific minds and she
completely
Thomas Edison's passion for innovation
during interviews he would openly talk
about how much he loved and appreciated
her Edison even bought her a luxurious
mansion called Glenn months in the
nearby town of West Orange Mina was
exactly the kind of wife that hasn't
needed she was able to manage the social
calendar to have parties with important
people in the industry and this only
improved his relationships with
investors however while Edison and Meena
were snoozing with investors Tesla and
Westinghouse was still hard at work
developing their alternating current in
1893 Tesla and Westinghouse debuted the
AC power system at the Chicago World's
Fair over a hundred thousand light bulbs
illuminated the night and people were in
total war it was clear who the better
inventor truly was Tesla and
Westinghouse they won the contract to
light up New York City after this Edison
he was furious and he began one of the
worst smear campaigns in history he
claims that AC power was too dangerous
for people's homes he demonstrated this
by electrocuting animals in public even
elephants Edison was also the man behind
demonstrating how human beings could be
killed in the electric chair however all
of his attempts to ruin Tesla and
Westinghouse they didn't work because AC
power prevailed and the war of the
currents was over
Thomas Edison could not make his mark on
the world as being the man who lit up
the worlds
however he succeeded in introducing the
motion picture camera to the United
States in 1888 Edison told the press I
am experimenting upon an instrument
which does for the eye what the
phonograph does for the ear which is the
recording and reproduction of things in
motion a Frenchman named Lula Pross had
developed the first motion picture
camera in France so Edison tasked one of
his employees William Kennedy Laurie
Dickson to improve it just enough to
file a patent they also created the
Kinetoscope which was a device where
people had to look into a viewfinder to
see the moving pictures after they'd
been captured Edison began to sell his
new devices to the masses just like he
had with his photographs Edison's lab
also began to double as a filming studio
because they wanted to sell these reels
to people to watch on their kinetoscopes
they began to release productions of
short films and charged people for
tickets to see these new movies however
once other film makers in New York City
started to produce films Edison would
try to sue them he wanted a monopoly for
any movie that was made using his
devices these filmmakers decided it was
time to get as far away as humanly
possible and yep they went to Hollywood
so if it wasn't for Thomas Edison's
litigious nature the movie capital of
the world would probably still be in New
York City over the course of his
lifetime Thomas Edison filed 1093
patents for new inventions he died in
1931 at his home in West Orange New
Jersey at the age of 84 today many
people have discredited Edison because
they believe that he doesn't actually
deserve all of the praise that he was
given over the years after hearing all
of the various terrible stories about
him it's easy to see why however you
cannot deny that this man he truly did
leave a lasting legacy and he inspired
countless numbers of inventors and
businessman you could also argue that
nearly every inventor does similar
things that Edison did no one is angry
at Elon Musk for the fact that he was
not the first to invent a car or a
rocket ship they're also not mad that he
has a huge staff in his factory who work
for him or that he is a public image so
do you think Thomas Edison was unfairly
criticized for his come
positive nature or was seat truly just a
terrible person who deserves all the
hate well let us know in the comments
below and as always I really hope you
enjoyed this video please do give it a
thumbs up if you did don't forget to
subscribe don't forget to hit that Bell
but most importantly please do check out
our sponsor brilliant at brilliant org
forward slash biographic to get a great
discount by going through that link it
also help support this show which is
amazing thank you for watching
[Music]